oneexchange from yesterday's hearing is
getting a lot of attention Democratic
senator Amy Klobuchar asked judge
Kavanaugh if he had ever blacked out
from too much alcohol you're saying
there's never been a case where you
drank so much that you didn't remember
what happened the night before or part
of what happened that's you're asking
about yeah blackout I don't know have
you could you answer the question judge
I just so you that's not happened is
that your answer
yeah and I'm curious if you have I have
no drinking problem nor do I she asked
me a question at the end that I
responded by asking her a question and I
didn't sorry I did that this is a tough
process senator Klobuchar prefaced the
question by talking about her father
struggles with alcohol joins us now from
Washington senator what do you make of
that exchange now that were a few hours
after it happened well I was thinking
that if I was in his courtroom and acted
like that he would have thrown me out
and I appreciated that he apologized but
at the same time he didn't really answer
the question and what I was trying to
get at was that you have this incredibly
convincing testimony in the morning from
dr. Ford you have other witnesses out
there that have said including his
college roommate that he gets
belligerent when he drinks others saying
that he would have memory lapses those
kinds of things and yet we are not
allowed to talk to those people under
oath or have the FBI look back and talk
to them and that is all we're asking for
here is a fair-minded process just like
we do with other nominees where you open
it up if new information comes out and
they're denying us that and of course
what does that make me think that they
are hiding something they don't want
these people to be questioned under oath
or by the FBI with criminal penalties if
they lie did you believe his apology to
be sincere to you and were you caught
off guard I you know I can't assess that
I think that he realized that it was not
good to be going back at a senator all I
was trying to say to him in a polite way
was that I've had alcoholism in my
family
dad had DWIs and took the consequences
for it and then went on to go into
treatment and is in a a at age 90 and I
was using that to say that happens in a
lot of families there's drinking
problems and then you have to get
through it
but in your case you're just denying
that this ever happened in the past and
that's what really bothers me for me it
is not that people don't drink in high
school it's is he telling the truth that
would figure it out is talking to the
witness that is passed a polygraph test
a lot of people are asking that question
senator about the truth and their ass
also questioned today is temperament do
you have questions about that and then
on the other hand people say well
someone who is fighting for their their
reputation who believes that their
credibility has been torn to shreds
wouldn't you expect that person to be
emotional emotional yes but what we saw
was a concerted effort on the other side
all afternoon not just him but the
Republican senators this chest-beating
like who could yell the most and who
could claim oh this isn't about her at
all this is about this concerted effort
and I believe what the strategy was with
the Republican side was to simply not
talk about her not talk about what
happened in the morning her moving
testimony where she didn't just testify
like victims do in a trial to a jury box
of strangers she testified and was
willing to go forward to the nation
didn't seem to me to have a political
bone in her body and then you have these
other people out there who are also
making claims and they need to be looked
into I'm a lawyer I don't like living in
an evidence free zone and for my
Republican colleagues who still haven't
decided
senator flake Murkowski collins their
fair-minded people they should at least
want one week for an FBI investigation
for the sake of the country to follow up
on these claims and Senator Republicans
at least publicly feel a bit more
confident now that they do have the
votes for confirmation what is your
response to chatter within democratic
circles that if he is in fact confirmed
that Democrats will try to impeach him
would you support that strategy first of
all I'm not even
thinking of that because I still believe
that they haven't decided and in my
conversations with them I believe them
when they say they haven't decided just
because we're having a committee vote
today committees have advanced nominees
to the floor who later get pulled back
or investigations occur that doesn't
mean that it's done and I know they're
trying to ram it through so more
evidence doesn't come out but I believe
the nation is focused on this right now
whether or not we should at least allow
as the American Bar Association the
group of lawyers from across the country
that found him to be well qualified for
this job they now came out last night
after watching this and said at least
allow the FBI to go back and look at
this just as George HW Bush ordered in
the Anita Hill case alright there's
still time to do that thank you very
much senator Klobuchar we appreciate
your time this morning thank you all of
you